- And yet in that volatile tinder box
of a time,
President Kennedy led with a steady hand.
Diffusing the most perilous moment
of the Cold War without
firing a single shot.
Enforcing the rights of young black
men and women to study at the university
of their choice.
Unleashing a core of young volunteers
as ambassadors for peace
in distant corners of the globe.
Setting America's sights on the moon
precisely because it was hard.
And willing to consider
the possibility that
we might not win the space race
because he had an unwavering faith
in the character of
the people that he led.
Resilient, optimistic, innovative,
and courageous.
It's worth remembering this.
The times in which
President Kennedy led us.
Because for many
Americans I know that this
feels like an uncertain
and even perilous time.
The forces of globalization
and technology have upended many
of our established
assumptions about the economy.
They've provided great opportunity
but also great inequality
and uncertainty for far too many.
Our politics remains filled
with division and discord.
And everywhere we see the risk of falling
into the refuge of tribe and clan
and anger at those who don't look like us
or have the same surnames
or pray the way we do.
And at such moments courage is necessary.
In such moments we need courage
to stand up to hate.
Not just in others
but in ourselves.
At such moments we need the courage
to stand up to dogma
not just in others
but in ourselves.
At such moments we need courage
to believe that together
we can tackle big challenges
like inequality and climate change.
At such moments it's necessary
for us to show courage in challenging
the status quo
and in fighting the good fight.
But also show the courage
to listen to one another
and seek common ground
and embrace principled compromise.
Courage,
President Kennedy knew,
requires something more than just
the absence of fear.
Any fool can be fearless.
Courage, true courage,
derives from that sense
of who we are,
what are our best selves,
what are our most important commitments?
And to believe that we can dig deep
and do hard things
for the enduring benefit of others.